the abortion response is scandalous
it is scandalous that of all of the
issues especially after this
absolute chaos pulling out of
afghanistan especially with inflation
going through the roof especially with
all of the domestic problems the
true crisis on the border millions of
illegal aliens flooding across we have
no idea who's coming over that allegedly
during a pandemic but these people
aren't even being tested for kovid
just
crisis after crisis after crisis the
only one that has aroused the full
energy of the federal government
is a little law in texas that lets some
kids live that's scandalous
that is that is a
an impediment to to people's
understanding of the world i mean that's
really
a big problem and it's especially
scandalous because the president
allegedly is a devout catholic that's
all we hear from the mainstream media
he's a catholic he's a devout catholic
he goes to mass every sunday he's such a
catholic
but catholics
are not permitted to support
abortion so gensake please explain this
for me
what our effort and what the focus of
the federal government is is to look for
every resource every lever at our
disposal to ensure women in texas have
the ability to seek health care
following up on the census law why does
the president support abortion when his
own catholic faith teaches abortion is
morally wrong
he believes that it's a woman's right
it's a woman's body and it's her choice
who does he believe then should look out
for the unborn child he believes that
it's up to a woman to make those
decisions and up to a woman to make
those decisions with her doctor i know
you've never faced those choices nor
have you ever been pregnant but for
women out there who have faced those
choices this is an incredibly difficult
thing president believes their rights
should be respected go ahead i think we
got to move on so first of all i've been
told by the government for many months
now that men can become pregnant i've
been told that it's not just women who
get pregnant now it's
there's a lot of confusion over who gets
pregnant for many months now all of a
sudden the white house sees it clearly
now that the
fictional right to abortion is being
threatened but i think saki just told on
herself i think saki just gave away the
game here because did you hear that last
sentence that she uttered she got very
emotional
borderline hysterical wouldn't answer
the question she says you you've never
been pregnant you for women who make
this [ __ ] this is a very difficult
choice
why is it difficult
why is it a difficult choice
you're telling me
that abortion
is not the taking of an innocent human
life
you've been telling me for a long time
radical left that abortion it's just the
removal of a parasite it's just a clump
of cells it's it's
no different than getting your appendix
removed so then why is it a difficult
choice
if your if your appendix needs to be
removed if you think that's best for
your health then that's a very easy
choice remove my appendix please easy i
don't need to worry about that i won't
face trauma after i've done that why is
abortion different why is it a difficult
choice because you know that it's the
ending of an innocent human life because
we all know it no matter how much we
want to suppress it we all have this
just nagging little feeling uh maybe
this is different why did hillary
clinton say that abortion should be safe
legal and rare why should it be rare if
it's just removing a parasite
if it's just your body your choice
because it's not because we all know
that it's not it's difficult because it
involves
people's natural
understanding that this is a baby and it
is wrong to kill your baby
and it also involves predators such as
abortionists such as the
pro-abortion media such as joe biden and
jansaki and the liberal establishment
and the elected officials who are all
preying on the fears and anxiety of
women who get pregnant who don't know
what to do
to just make it all go away or at least
pretend to make it all go away by
killing their baby that's why it's
difficult
it's a difficult decision because one
grapples with one's conscience on the
one hand and one's temptations on the
other that's why it's difficult
with labor day coming up i like to
support american labor okay i always
like to support american labor and yet
did you know that 80 percent over 80 of
the grass-fed beef sold in the united
states is actually imported from
overseas
that's why i get my meat from
goodranchers.com because their product
is 100
american when you buy your steak and
chicken from good ranchers not only are
you getting amazing meat but you're also
supporting american farms by working
together with local farms and ranches
and shipping straight to your door
goodranchers.com is a safe and
convenient way to order your meat they
save your family money and help the
american farmer
goodranchers.com has an amazing
selection all of it at half the price of
online competitors you get the
steakhouse quality you deserve with the
price every family can afford i had the
burgers what was it two three nights ago
absolutely magnificent juiciest most
delicious burgers i've ever had labor
day right around the corner order the
best meat today goodranchers.com to buy
now or subscribe today save 20 on each
box of mouthwatering meats subscribing
brings the cost down to less than five
bucks a meal which is insane right now
get an additional 20 bucks off in free
express shipping if you go to
goodranchers.com use code knowles at
checkout 20 bucks off in free express
shipping
goodranchers.com know where your meet
comes from with goodranchers.com
on the point of joe biden being catholic
what she is admitting here is that joe
biden is not a practicing catholic
to be a practicing catholic you cannot
support abortion
when when she says well look yeah joe's
catholic but he believes that a woman
has the right to kill her baby he isn't
she is admitting he's not a practicing
catholic and i know there's some
confusion on this point among certainly
among the left but even among
conservatives and they'll say well
michael you're just gatekeeping religion
well michael you're just nitpicking well
what you're holier than now you're
saying that someone can't be a catholic
if they don't agree with every single
thing
the catholic faith is different than
some other faiths
in that the catholic faith is
an incarnational faith that says that
there are real obligations and those
real obligations will be defined by real
people in a real church
that has real authority
to make you do certain things and if you
don't do certain things then that church
that real place led by real people
including a real pope has the authority
to define
that you are not practicing the faith
what i mean by that is
this you've got to do certain things
there are real sacraments you've got you
actually do have to go to mass on sunday
but that's not enough you also have to
go to confession that's another
sacrament you also have to follow
the guidelines of the catholic church
the moral
demands of the catholic faith
and
some are more demanding than others so
one one objection i often hear is well
michael but the catholic church is
against the death penalty which is sort
of true but not totally true the
catholic church is a prudential matter
discourages the death penalty it says
it's inadmissible now even that's the
most radical language that's from pope
francis or that practically speaking it
shouldn't be performed
in most places
but as pope benedict said
quite well there can be a legitimate
disagreement among catholics thomas
aquinas defended the death penalty st
paul defends the death penalty many
popes defended the death penalty blessed
pope pius ix carried out many death
penalties in the papal states obviously
there at the very least there can be
difference of opinion there cannot be a
difference of opinion on abortion
for 1900 years at least the catholic
church has taught clearly that abortion
is not
permissible you can't it is a
non-negotiable issue
so joe biden has to choose which faith
he wants to follow his catholic faith
that he tries to use to score political
points or his progressive faith which is
his actual religion and before you tell
me that a man's religion should have
nothing to do with his politics it
should have nothing to do with the way
he governs i will point out a man's gods
have everything to do with how he
governs everybody's got to serve
somebody and so his moral his ethical
his views of the of man's relationship
to
man to the state to god to metaphysics
that is going to define his government
the left knows this the left told us
this in the 1970s the feminist said the
personal is political personal choices
decisions behaviors have a political
effect and conservatives have made fun
of them but they're right they're right
and
they knew it then they don't want to
admit that it's true in this case as
well i think we should all admit that it
is right and we need to question
what gods are our leaders serving
[Music]
[Music]